vamos a las noticias económicas y para
el repaso la editora Daniela Blandón
Daniela Buen día para usted Hola Ángela
Buenos días por segunda vez no Sí señora
para completar este segmento Daniela
vamos a empezar esta vez con la
plataforma de Netflix que ha cumplido su
promesa de empezar a cobrar más a las
familias o a las personas que se unen
para tener una misma cuenta pero en
diferentes hogares Ajá que es algo que
sucede muy frecuentemente El gigante de
transmisión lleva meses insistiendo en
que una cuenta de Netflix es para uso de
un solo hogar pero parece que la mayoría
de los suscriptores no lo entienden y
han hecho un intercambio desenfrenado de
contraseñas por eso advirtió que enviará
un aviso a los miembros que comparten
sus cuentas fuera del hogar al menos en
Estados Unidos y les va a decir si los
suscriptores que hoy pagan planes
estándar o Premium que cuestan entre 15
y 20 dólares por mes quieren que otra
persona que viva fuera de su casa
utilice su contraseña deberán pagar 8
dólares adicionales por mes y es que
según sus cuentas hay 230 millones de
usuarios pero unos 100 millones
adicionales están Disfrutando del
servicio de sus amigos y familiares sin
vivir con ellos y de manera gratuita
esta política más estricta ya empezó a
probarla en Canadá también en Nueva
Zelanda en Portugal y España y en unos
países de América Latina en temas más
delicados daniel en Estados Unidos sigue
corriendo el reloj el plazo para que sea
alce el límite de la deuda pues queda
una semana para que se dé este temido
escenario de incumplimiento y las
negociaciones sobre el aumento en el
techo de deuda Siguen estancadas con los
demócratas queriendo más impuestos y los
republicanos buscando recortes de gastos
hoy en la mañana va a haber una nueva
reunión entre el presidente Joe biden y
el líder de la oposición Kevin mccarthy
para tratar de destrabarlas Lo cierto es
que ambas partes han dicho tajantemente
que el default no está sobre la mesa
muy bien Daniela no hay no hay
suficiente digamos calma para las
personas de todas maneras que se ven
beneficiadas por el gasto no así que hay
algunos que ya se preparan para un
posible incumplimiento claro parece una
noticia macroeconómica pero en realidad
es micro Porque algunos jubilados y
grupos de servicio social ya están
haciendo planes de contingencia esto
porque sin fondos suficientes para
operar desde el primero de junio
estarían entre los directamente
afectados con esta falta de recursos una
encuesta liderada por día de sociales
entre casi 1700 personas dice que el 66%
está muy o extremadamente preocupado por
esta situación y que cuatro de cada 10
Está siguiendo muy de cerca las
negociaciones también son más quienes
apoyan al presidente biden que a los
demócratas y a los republicanos en este
pulso el número de personas
potencialmente afectadas sería enorme ya
que según la oficina del censo en 2020
aproximadamente el 35% de los hogares en
este país tenía a alguien que recibía
beneficios del seguro social y una cifra
similar recibía beneficios de Medicaid
dos de los programas que estarían en
vilo entonces seguimos en lo mismo a la
espera de que haya una decisión Daniela
Mientras tanto le propongo que avancemos
con otra noticia importante y tiene que
ver con el Reino Unido porque aunque la
inflación está cediendo eso a todas
luces no es suficiente claro y se dio
bastante porque en abril la inflación
anual frente a la de marzo que superaba
el 10% pues bajó más de un punto
porcentual sin embargo todavía está
lejos de la meta del Banco Central que
es del 2% anual en este país los precios
de la energía sí han bajado Pero hay
mucha preocupación por otros rubros muy
importantes de la canasta familiar pero
dejemos que sea nuestra corresponsal en
Londres Luisa Pulido quien nos entregue
detalles
los expertos califican de agridulce que
la inflación en el Reino Unido haya
empezado a ceder en abril se registró en
8.7% ya está en una sola cifra pero
lejos de ser una noticia alentadora
sigue siendo preocupante para la mayoría
de los hogares en el país porque los
precios de los alimentos siguen
disparados de acuerdo con las cifras ya
están en un
19.1 por ciento uno de los niveles
récord por supuesto y que hace que los
alimentos de la canasta básica como los
de la leche la azúcar y la pasta estén
por las nubes por supuesto el llamado es
aquel gobierno adopte medidas urgentes
para que ayudan a la población en medio
de la crisis del costo de vida Esta
noticia de la inflación no es alentadora
para la economía británica porque la del
Reino Unido la inflación de este país
sigue siendo la más alta de Europa
occidental y de la Unión Europea los
mercados también esperaban que bajar a
más a un
8.2% Así que no cumplió las expectativas
y también bien importante la inflación
subyacente subió a niveles récord en 30
años el ministro de finanzas Jeremy Hunt
dijo hoy que el Reino Unido la economía
británica está lejos de ganar esta
batalla a la inflación Pues ahí está la
cosa Daniela vamos a cerrar con su cifra
por esta mañana pues entre uno y dos
millones de dólares que espera recibir
la casa de subastas californiana
propstore por el vestido que utilizó la
princesa leia usado por Kerry Fisher en
Star Wars el vestido saldrá a subasta a
partir del 28 de junio junto con otros
1400 objetos que se han usado en las
pantallas grandes y chicas
hollywoodenses ya lo practiqué el nombre
Bueno hablamos Entonces mañana además
economía Claro que sí